[Music]
all right i have a story
of this former library employee
who stole 1.3 million dollars in printer
toner
what 1.3 million dollars how
wow that's a lot of toner accumulated or
in one day
okay that's a flock ton of printer tools
it was from october of 2007 to july
2019 but still it was a lot of money in
toner
i don't even know but i can steal that
much what does that look like how much
do you put that in one room how much
toner is that
but i can tell you though that for that
time period
laser toners printer toner i don't know
ink yeah laserjet are like i could tell
you how much they should have
been using because lasers this size oh
[ __ ] well you could take it home no
one's gonna
check you that's right so she's taking
one a day well this is a male
uh randall so randall granddale randall
is he purchased
my bad for assuming a librarian's a
woman damn it i'm so sexist
it was a librarian yeah or a library i
thought it was just a thief was a woman
that's why
oh that stole it in the library you
would joe you still would
anything like she was thinking it was a
thief that's that was a woman
never mind just kidding okay so randall
worked at the austin public library
he worked in accounting and he purchased
at least 1.5 million dollars worth of
toner from that time span that i gave
you
and they're saying the auditor's office
estimated that they would have only
needed about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars worth
in that time frame instead of 1.5
million dollars worth
what what if he was printing a lot he
wasn't he was he was printing the bible
every day hot red-handed
red ink with the cctv footage of him
walking away
with boxes of toner and putting them in
his trunk and they also
followed the trail he was selling it on
ebay and he was selling it
oh so he was selling it okay what a
weird hustle
hey it makes sense though but it goes
under the one of those
under the radar uh under the radar it is
so this is the austin public library
running library that's
beautiful that library is so fine
she lowkey thick think as [ __ ] i was
just gonna say biggest buzz
why would you need books these days
though
that's a good point and then this is
randall being caught
with printer and telling them with the
fresh fade though i know look at that
line with that library
dude who's who's random barber what what
he's selling toner just so you can
afford cuts every day
1.5 [ __ ] million the way he was doing
it is he would show up to work
uh more than 30 minutes before his
his time because he knew for a fact that
there was way less
security there they got less people and
so he was able to get away with that i
don't trust early people
yup they're sneaky never trust him and
and so
yeah like he was caught so he was saying
that
he was actually getting all this extra
toner to make deliveries to other
libraries but they have other employees
to do that job
and he just wanted to be a good employee
and like do the
do the extra mile because he was going
to take it have you all ever stolen from
work
yeah yeah yeah i guess same so randall
he's just like us
you know he's relatable but hold on i
stole from necessity this fool was like
like stealing and i mean i guess he
needed money but not that much money
so when you say that i picture you being
like just getting a loaf of bread and
like eating it in the corner because
it's all yours
i needed this it was sadder i i would
steal rolls of toilet paper
away from where from work where was that
where was work
jk studios oh no no no he's way better
this is like the best place to steal
me and joe me and joe don't give a [ __ ]
we don't even know
i already have like three things in my
backyard
i'm never missing anything we had
somebody
steal from us and and and let us borrow
what they stole from us what yeah wait
tell me more
oh wait i think you heard this was it
cameras yeah it was it was
camera lenses it was like a two thousand
dollar lens in turn
that was a klepto and then they stole
from us
and then let us borrow what they stole
and we're like man thank god you have an
extra cause [ __ ] you know like
we lost it so how'd you find out this
guy's a detective and he was able to
find
my wife was oh so like my wife always
had funny vibes
around him because like after she would
leave her table if he walks by like
whatever it was left would always be
like this
so she was like wait i think this guy's
looking through our laptops and our
phones and stuff
and then one time i think we're all
shooting and then he goes in the office
and like grabs something real quick and
i think that's when she came out and
told us like hey you know that phone you
guys found
i think he's on the phone we left it on
a corner and then he pocketed it
yup and then after that uh he he said
can we borrow the lens and then we match
the bark he matched the uh
cereal to the box that we had the box
that we had
good thing we kept the box yeah and
while we were confronting we're like all
right well we can open up the car and
beat your ass right now
or we could call the cops or what do you
want to do and he goes
i feel so violated right now and a bird
[ __ ] on him
and then when a bird [ __ ] on him he
was like ah
that [ __ ] cried i had the
audacity to say he felt violent yes
this is ew these [ __ ] sociopaths do
they're like oh i just want to get out
of trouble and we i was like about to
laugh
we weren't even bullying him or we were
just like like hey like trying to take
it step by step like
can we search your car please because we
we have a hunch and i'm gonna get in
and if we don't find anything our bad
super sorry so it wasn't even like
aggressing or anything like that
and he started flipping out like crazy
he was so theatrical because
we we saw him close the back door of his
car so then we're like
let us uh check that out or you could
just give it to us and he goes i'll show
you
everything and then he pops out the
trunk right and he starts saying
you want to see this you want to violate
my privacy we're like no we want to see
what's in the backseat we're like
going to the front seat he pops the hood
yeah i'll show you everything were you
guys laughing you had to
me and joe kept looking at each other
with you know the laughing eyes were
like this [ __ ] oh my god oh my
goodness
wow i see i have too much guilt to be a
klepto yeah
i have too much girl and during that
time i was like i'll just go to the 99
cent store and buy toilet paper
oh wait no no i'm sorry toilet paper and
things like that i'll steal
but like like property in that sense i
can't do it oh [ __ ] no i've done it
when i was a server i worked at a
restaurant that was connected to the
mall right so they would give mall
employees
uh an employee discount so when the mall
employees come in you would say
oh you know i got a i got a mall person
at this table and then the
the manager would do like the 30
discount wow that's a big discount yeah
30
so what we would do is all the servers
is whenever
somebody paid in cash anybody we would
say
oh like oh i got a mall discount on
table blah blah so they would they this
table had already paid
for the full price in cash so we would
take the 30
receipt now and then we would pocket the
30 percent because the person already
paid for the hundred percent
and then it got to a point where they
had to stop them all
the whole mall
the west field goes bankrupt
wait i kind of get it but i don't get it
but well yeah yeah so so check it out so
check it out
a regular person would pay a hundred
percent of their bill right let's say
it's a hundred dollars and you take that
receipt
so a hundred dollars is their meal right
right so like they've already paid they
left
100 bucks they paid for it yes cash cash
is the important part so i go
hey to my manager after they already
gone and left i'm like
this table was employee can you discount
the the receipt cause they're not paying
attention to where the tables are at
they're like sure
so they discounted 30 off now the bill
is only seventy dollars
it gives him seventy he keeps the three
i keep the thirty
that's smart yeah even though they
weren't an employee even though they
weren't an employee i'm so pretty
thank you for walking walking me through
that sick bro
wow yeah so you're a criminal yeah
yeah money laundering we all are the
confession on tape
no one's innocent i didn't take it
offensive when
the the the the intern stole from i mean
like even i didn't take it personally i
just wanted the lens back i'm like i
stole from my job
right i'm not taking it personally
you're not trying to diss me i mean he
was a great intern like
like we even thought if we just rigged
the house with cameras right
and he just keeps letting us borrow what
he stole yeah it's like [ __ ] it you know
let's keep them within the system
that's how like lenient we are i'm like
well [ __ ] we stole who cares you know
but if that restaurant saw this i was
just kidding i never did that
because you've never actually announced
which restaurants you've ever worked at
so no one whatever the family's
restaurant thai smile when it was
connected to the mall i think
i think this is the thing is like if
people can they will
and um i don't think people are bad but
i think people are constantly looking
for loopholes i think
generally most people are honorable but
there are a few
who create the what what what honor is
to them you know
when you're younger too because you feel
more invincible you're just like
whatever this is in all businesses we
budget for
theft right right no actually so my mom
owns a restaurant as well
and she has a lot of quarters you know
so sometimes she'll just have like a
bowl of quarters at the crib
and i was addicted to crane machines at
a point in my life
i would [ __ ] steal all her quarters
me too i was a quarter stealer from my
family
is it stealing though if it's your mom
it's a borrow mama i got you you know
i'll buy you something one day
yeah i mean we'll go on a cruise um we
did go on a cruise
uh but so my debt is clear um
but i would literally like just like
take these quarters and just waste them
on cream machines i was obsessed like
you know yes plaza
yes plaza and also the other one uh next
to t-bar in
our arcadia wait which one's yes which
one's diamond which one's focused
is by din tai fun yeah yeah that one
yeah is on del mar and saying and
valeating or san gabriel valley
something like that but the ones with
the crane machines you know you were
just i need that [ __ ] kero p
i would spend like yes the karopi's the
rilakkumas like
i need that [ __ ] hello kitty now i do
kind of have a gambling problem is
what i'm saying so i would spend like a
hundred dollars and get nothing what
you suck
or she's determined i'm resilient i know
yeah i'm very determined and
so i would just like not eat for a week
so i looked i looked really good in 2009
um but but yeah so i definitely took
quarters from my mom
wait you were a 19 year old 18 year old
doing this yeah
oh 19 20 21 even
yeah and you got no stuffed animals no
no i do have
i do have like you go to the indian
casino and gamble at 18.
no i when i see a crane machine like i i
get like you know like relapses
don't go to japan like my eyes will roll
back
um but but yeah i do have a good amount
of
yesterday's story for you then because
uh we ended up talking about this guy
that
he was playing a crane machine for two
like 200 times and he couldn't win he
called the police the police came over
they made the arcade operator play and
the arcade operator played more than 300
times and then at that point is when
they moved the stuff
so then it could be heck winnable it is
kind of rigged there's something
sometimes the claws
looser you know what i mean yeah
sometimes it's just like
are you good now though can you do you
know which ones you could and you could
you have an eye like yeah if i just
pushed that one i could get that one
i feel like i'm good at those like asian
ones but the ones that like denny's or
like
actual arcades i feel like it's set up
differently yeah it's different it's
different it's a different brand
then when you finally get one man it's
like you know
i've never gotten just all the stuffed
animals literally
it's all like electronic ones no i don't
do those i don't do those oh do you use
the crank i'm a plusher
type of [ __ ] do you use the crane to
push it or do you grab it actually
sometimes you need one to kind of you
know wing woman the other
a little bit yeah so i just i'm just
waiting to use the first 50
to push it and then the last 100 to pick
it up
[Music]
you